Throughout this course,
you're going to need to test
your site on different devices.
So, pull out your credit card and
get ready to order all of these
devices that you see behind you.
>> [LAUGH] Pete, I, I don't think
we can ask everybody to do that.
>> Fair enough.
Instead, you could just use
a simulator or emulators.
Simulators and
emulators are great tools.
While they're not always 100% accurate,
because they're on different hardware
and sometimes have a different code
path, they'll often get the job done.
And for this course, we'll be just fine.
In this course, Cam and I are going to
use an emulator built into Chrome, but
be sure to check out some of the other
ones including the iOS simulator, and
some of the cloud based services
in the instructor notes.
>> Nice, I like that a lot more,
emulation is definitely
the much cheaper solution.
>> It is,
here lemme show you how it works.